- One use case is
to use BigQuery
for Preprocessing
of the training data.
So the TensorFlow
or the Machine Learning Engine
or ML Engine itself
is not suited
for the duty of preprocessing
or collecting all the data
from Enterprise Systems.
So you can use BigQuery
as a data bank
so you can gather all the data
coming from the Enterprise
application server,
with server databases.
All imported to the BigQuery and
do some preprocessing on that,
then you can add exported data,
other training data
to the TensorFlow or ML Engine.
So let's take a look at the
actual demonstrations for that.
Here, I'd like to use
the Cloud Datalab
to do--to use the BigQuery
for preparation,
or preprocessing
and use the TensorFlow
to train your Neural Network model
for machine learning analytics.
So this is just something
I have prepared
that is called
Classifying Manhattan.
Here we are importing the bunch
of the location data
from BigQuery and trained the
Neural Network model
to classify whether each
location is Manhattan or not.
So...
We clear all the cells first.
And now let's take a look at
what kind of the training datas
that we'll be using
by executing this query.
So I'll be using the--
another public data set
called NYPD Collisions.
That because
all of the car accidents
happened in the New York City.
We see timestamp and borough
and latitude and longitude.
But you cannot use this raw data
as it is.
You have to do preprocessing
to that.
Because you can see that some
rows
doesn't have any borough data.
Some rows doesn't have latitude
and longitude.
We have to remove
useless garbage data.
So again, you can use
the BigQuery
to do this kind
of the preprocessing.
And also, I want to have
a new program.
Is Manhattan --
to have a flag.
That flag represents whether
the latitude and longitude
is inside Manhattan or not.
So this is the SQL I'll be using
for preprocessing
and let me execute it.
And also, you can also
execute another
called to extract all the data
from BigQuery,
import it into
the Python.
So now you have all the data
imported into Python code.
So as you can see, by using
Cloud Datalab,
you can seamlessly integrate
the BigQuery query
with the Python code you write.
And you can continue use
your scikit-learn
or the NumPy code
running on BigQuery.
Sorry about my voice.
So now we have the training data
set.
One is Manhattan.
This could be used as a label
for training,
whether each location is in
Manhattan or not,
and pairs of the latitude
and longitude.
10,000 rows.
So let's do the feature scaling.
Before starting training,
usually in machine learning,
you have to clean the data out.
Clean out--cleansing of the
data.
And one important thing there is
to do is feature scaling.
And if you do the scaling
and plotting the data,
you can see the training data
set would look like this.
Now everything is centered on...
The, uh...zero.
But still, you can see the shape
of Manhattan here.
You can still--
You can even see there's Central
Park inside the data set.
So this will be the training
data set for neural network.
We'll be splitting the data
into training data
and test data.
And use TensorFlow to define
your neural network.
Here I'm using TensorFlow,
especially the so-called high--
what is that?
High-level API of TensorFlow.
And this is one of the features
we have recently announced
with TensorFlow 1.0
where you can just write
a few lines of Python code
to define neural networks.
Before that, we had been using
so-called low-level API
where you have to define all
the competition graph--
low-level competition graph to
define your own neural networks.
But now you can just write a few
lines of code with Python.
So you can see we are defining
deep neural networks
with the four hidden layers
and each hidden layer
has 20 nodes.
We have the neural networks.
Let's check the current accuracy
of the neural networks
and how these neural networks
can classify Manhattan
with that,
before doing the actual
training.
So now you'll be seeing the map
classed by the neural networks.
So this is how a neural network
thinks
where the Manhattan is before
training.
So because this is before
training,
the neural network
is stupid enough--
is too stupid to classify
Manhattan.
He thinks this is Manhattan.
So this is where we have to
train the neural network model.
The accuracy is 75%.
So you can write
a full loop
to repeatedly call the
fit method
to train the model by using the
training data set.
So now it should be showing
the--
gradually showing the better
accuracy.
So you are seeing that neural
network model is trying
to adjust how to classify
each data points
to get better result.
So that network is getting much
smarter and smarter
as you have saw on the Playground
demonstration.
Yes, it's getting much, much
better.
So now training is finish.
We got the 99.8% accuracy.
And now neural network is trying
to split the Manhattan
and Brooklyn with the very
sophisticated code between them